[موسيقى] في عام 2008 كشفت البحرين النقاب عن مركز التجارة العالمي كمنارة للتمويل والتجارة ورمز لدور البلاد كمركز مالي رائد في الخليج ، حيث اجتذب إطار تنظيمي راسخ للغاية الكثير من البنوك للانتقال إلى البحرين ولكن فقط بعد ثلاث سنوات ، ضربت موجة الربيع العربي سواحل هذا البلد ، تقلص نمو الناتج المحلي الإجمالي للبحرين من أكثر من ستة في المائة في عام 2008 إلى أقل من 2 في المائة في عام 2011. على مدى العقد التالي ، تفاقمت المشاكل فقط مع انهيار أسعار النفط وانتشار جائحة عالمي مع التقلبات في أسعار النفط بعد انهيار أسعار النفط في عام 2015 ، كان هناك الكثير من الإصلاحات لتقليل عجز الميزانية ، ثم في عام 2020 أثناء الطمع ، تقلص الاقتصاد بنسبة 5.4 في المائة ، ولكن الآن تتطلع البلاد إلى إعادة تنشيط اقتصادها ، حيث أعلنت مؤخرًا عن برنامج إقامة دائمة المعروفة باسم التأشيرة الذهبية من أجل جذب أفضل المواهب ، تأتي الأخبار بعد إعلان في أكتوبر من العام الماضي عن 30 مليار دولار  استراتيجية الانتعاش
حددت حكومة البحرين ستة
قطاعات للاستثمار
والتحسين تتطلع المملكة إلى تنويع
اقتصادها حيث يوفر النفط والغاز حاليًا
حوالي 75
من الإيرادات الحكومية ، والهدف الرئيسي
لجذب 2.5 مليار دولار من
الاستثمار الأجنبي المباشر بحلول عام
2023.
مبلغ كبير من التمويل المطلوب الذي من
المفترض أن يأتي من الاستثمارات الخاصة ، تشمل
بعض المشاريع البارزة
بناء خمس مدن جديدة وجزر اصطناعية
ومنطقة تجارية مع الولايات المتحدة
وطريق جديد بطول 25 كيلومترًا
وجسر سكة حديد يربط البحرين
بالمملكة العربية السعودية والمنطقة.  أكبر
خطط جريئة للاقتصاد ستشمل
كل الاقتصاد بهدف
إعادة البحرين لتتماشى مع جيرانها الخليجيين الأكبر
جومانا كاراتشاي سي إن إن لسوق
الشرق الأوسط